en esta ocasión vamos a hablar acerca de
la congruencia la congruencia vamos a
escribirlo bien la congruencia una forma
de pensar en ello es una equivalencia en
forma en álgebra cuando algo es igual a
otra cosa nos indica que la cantidad es
la misma en este caso hablamos de formas
congruencia indica que la forma es la
misma y el tamaño es el mismo así que
podemos pensar en la congruencia como
algo equivalente a decir que es igual en
forma y tamaño
dibujemos un ejemplo aquí voy a dibujar
un triángulo
de esta manera
y tenemos otro triángulo que lo voy a
dibujar de otra forma este triángulo lo
voy a dibujar
si pudiéramos rotar y mover este primer
triángulo podríamos ver que es
exactamente igual a este segundo
triángulo siempre y cuando no se cambien
las longitudes de los lados o la medida
de los ángulos y solamente se roten
muevan o volteen lo anoto si solo se
rota
o voltea
voltear
se pueden realizar estos tres
procedimientos para lograr que ambos
triángulos se ven iguales si esto se da
entonces ambos triángulos serán
congruentes vamos a etiquetar los
vértices de estos triángulos vamos a
poner a llamar a este extremo de acá
este de acá lo llamamos b
y a este de acá lo llamamos en este caso
aquí voy a llamarle equis y apareció
otra cosa menos la x x
este punto de acá va a ser
y este de aquí va a ser set
si afirmamos que ambos triángulos son
congruentes si yo afirmo que el
triángulo
b c es congruente
con este símbolo estoy indicando este
igual con esta parte curva aquí arriba
estoy indicando la palabra congruencia
si es congruente con el triángulo
x y z x y z
entonces los lados correspondientes
serán iguales al igual que los ángulos
eso implica
esto implica que el extremo ave lo voy a
remarcar aquí
el segmento que va de a ave
es igual al extremo que corresponde
o al segmento que corresponde entre x
esto quiere decir que el lado ave
es igual al lado x
incluso podemos ver en la forma en que
definimos los triángulos
corresponde con x
v corresponde con james y se corresponde
con zeta
así que el segmento ave es igual al
segmento xy
y si no cuentan con colores como lo he
señalado acá pueden usar o denotar que
estos son iguales usando un pequeñito
segmento de línea aquí ya acá indicando
que estos dos son iguales
e incluso podemos despreciar este
enunciado así que el segmento ave el
segmento de línea b es congruente con el
segmento
de línea x
la congruencia entre dos segmentos de
líneas significa que son del mismo
tamaño así que estos dos enunciados
significan lo mismo podemos hacer esto
con cada uno de los lados
correspondientes en ambos triángulos
puedo indicar con diferentes colores que
el segmento hace es igual que el
segmento x z
lo puedo señalar también con estas dos
líneas indicando que estos son iguales y
con otro color indicar que el segmento
entre beige
es lo mismo que el segmento entre z y yo
también lo puedo señalar aquí con en
este caso tres líneas pequeñas para
enseñar que todos estos dos elementos
son iguales así que aquí escribo por
ejemplo que el segmento a c
es igual al segmento xz y también indicó
que el lado de ce es igual al lado de
zeta
ahora que sabemos que los lados
correspondientes son iguales también
sabemos que los ángulos correspondientes
son iguales como el ángulo que se forma
entre este lado rojo y este lado azul
este ángulo es el mismo que tenemos
entre este lado rojo y el lado azul en
este también
así pues la medida del ángulo de a c es
igual a la medida del ángulo
x set
es decir el ángulo de acs que acabo de
indicar es igual al ángulo de x set este
ángulo de acá
lo mismo podemos hacer con los demás
ángulos de este triángulo vamos a elegir
otros colores
este ángulo de acá es el mismo que se
encuentra acá la medida del ángulo
d
a veces es igual a la medida del ángulo
x jay-z x
z y de hecho también puedo indicar con
otra anotación esto mismo por ejemplo en
este enunciado de aquí arriba también lo
puede expresar como que el ángulo b a c
es congruente con el ángulo
x z estos dos enunciados son
equivalentes bueno continuemos con
nuestros ángulos internos
puedo decir finalmente que este ángulo
entre a se ve que estoy señalando aquí
en morado la medida del ángulo a cb es
igual a la medida del ángulo que se
forma con x
zg es igual a la medida del ángulo x
zeta
ahora vamos a enfocarnos en cómo
demostrar la congruencia entre dos
triángulos ya que si podemos demostrar
eso entre dos triángulos entonces
podremos decir que todos estos
enunciados se cumplen
ahora vamos a comenzar con un axioma o
postulado lo voy a escribir aquí axioma
axioma
o postulado que suenan palabras muy
elegantes muy exóticas postulado
ambas palabras son muy sofisticadas
simplemente significa que algo que
asumimos es verdad
en particular el axioma se distingue por
ser algo que es evidentemente cierto
como una verdad universal algo que se da
por sentado y que no se puede demostrar
el postulado es algo similar es algo que
decimos que se asume que es cierto para
entonces hacer otras inferencias a
partir de ello pero para propósitos de
una clase introductoria de geometría
ambos términos se usan de manera
indistinta un axioma o postulado central
para la demostración que queremos
encontrar es el asumir que si todos los
lados son congruentes entonces estaremos
tratando con triángulos congruentes a
veces a esto se le llama el postulado
lado lado lado o 3 él es esto significa
entonces lado
lado
lados
esto significa en estas tres él es lo
que nos dice es que si tenemos dos
triángulos voy a dibujar otros dos
triángulos aquí ahora los voy a dibujar
de esta manera
así
y otros de otro color vamos a dibujarlo
en otra posición
y así si tenemos estos dos triángulos y
sabemos que los lados correspondientes
son iguales es decir que el lado este y
este son iguales y que el lado vamos a
señalarlo aquí con colores este lado de
aquí
que corresponde a este lado de aquí
también son iguales son congruentes
tienen el mismo tamaño y finalmente que
este otro lado de acá este lado de aquí
acá
es igual a este otro lado que estoy
señalando acá
estos dos lados también son iguales
entonces cuando tenemos los tres lados
iguales en ambos triángulos entonces
ambos triángulos van a ser congruentes
esto nos indica
cuando tenemos lado lado lado que estos
tres lados son iguales en ambos
triángulos
este triángulo va a ser congruente con
este triángulo y con esto podemos
afirmar todos estos otros enunciados
como verdaderos que los ángulos internos
también de estos triángulos van a ser
congruentes este ángulo va a ser
congruente con este ángulo de acá este
ángulo va a ser congruente con este otro
de acá y este ángulo de aquí también va
a ser congruente con este ángulo de acá
y para saber por qué estos son
postulados válidos para comenzar tomamos
uno de los triángulos y ahora veamos si
podemos construir otro triángulo que
tenga las mismas longitudes de los lados
pero sea diferente aún cuando se pueda
mover voltear o rotar
así que voy a construir aquí otro
triángulo
este lado del triángulo
voy a poner de otro color en este lado
ahí está y finalmente voy a dibujar
este otro lado
así que para este otro triángulo vamos a
dibujar este lado en esta posición
vamos a dibujar el lado naranja
no sé aquí abajo no mejor aquí arriba lo
dibujamos pero igual en otro con otra
dirección
más o menos así y nuestro lado morado lo
pondremos
algo así claramente esto no es un
triángulo tendríamos que estos lados
girar los para que se unan estos
extremos y hay dos maneras de hacerlo
una manera es rotando los hacia esta
dirección de manera que cada lado nos va
a quedar este lado
y lo roto así
y me va a quedar
algo así
y este lado morado
lo roto se va a unir acá y me va a
quedar así de manera que estos dos
triángulos son iguales finalmente ahora
otra forma de hacerlo como les comentaba
es rotar estos extremos estos lados pero
ahora hacia acá este acá y este acá
vamos a hacerlo tomamos el lado naranja
más o menos es tamaño lo giramos lo
rotamos
y este lado a morado también lo tomamos
de aquí lo rotamos hacia acá de manera
que venimos a los extremos y nos queda
un triángulo igual y sólo tendremos que
rotarlo para este lado hacia acá para
que quede con la misma forma y la misma
proporción que este primer triángulo
iconos espero que quede claro que este
axioma del lado lado lado es razonable
como inicio para confiar en que si los
lados correspondientes de dos triángulos
son iguales entonces serán triángulos
congruentes y por lo tanto también los
ángulos internos no se dan